we did not discuss at all that Homeless
pimp has shorts on and this is the first
time you've ever seen his legs ever in
your life you've never seen homelessness
I was blocked by the TV I didn't see it
stay on yesterday was the hottest day
ever recorded on earth what what like
like cumulatively because they're taking
it to a fact account 130 degrees in
Arizona and negative 30 in Antarctica
and the cumulative average was 62.6
since since we've even had this record
yes 62.4 was the previous record in
August of 2016. could be caused by
recent heat waves in U.S Canada and
Europe uh you think yeah I mean this is
the that's the globe warming then yes
basically wow so that's why that's why
you wore shorts yeah she's like oh wait
so you take the whole world of averages
together and so I'm wearing shorts
[Laughter]